La réincarnation : Le cycle de la vie.
De tout temps, l'homme s'est demandé
d'où il venait et qui il était.
De tout temps, il a cherché à découvrir le sens de sa vie,
car la conscience humaine possède la faculté
de se connaître elle-même
et de tirer profit de cette expérience.
La nature est la grande maîtresse de l'homme.
Elle constitue l'espace vital dont il fait partie.
Ainsi, l'homme a observé la nature,
source de savoir et d'apprentissage des lois de la vie.
Le jour, il a observé le mouvement du soleil,
la vue se lever à l'horizon.
Puis disparaître au couchant.
La nuit, il a observé l'espace infini du ciel étoilé.
Et le déclin de la Lune.
Encore et toujours, l'homme a vu naître la vie,
vécue l'époque de la floraison,
le temps de la croissance et de la maturité.
L'homme a appris à s'adapter aux changements
des saisons et à se soumettre avec humilité
aux périodes de pénurie.
Il a connu la richesse de la vie
et la beauté de la nature qui l'entoure.
Et son cœur s'est empli de respect devant le génie créateur
de toutes ces merveilles et de toute cette perfection.
Très tôt, l'homme a compris ce qu'était la vie.
Une alliance harmonieuse de rythme et d'équilibre,
semblable au mouvement du pendule,
oscillant en permanence d'un pôle à l'autre.
Tout ce qui vit obéit à cette loi élémentaire de la polarité
et ne peut exister que si cet équilibre est respecté.
À l'inspiration succèdent l'expiration,
à la veille, le sommeil,
à la vie, la mort.
Cependant, tout comme le jour nouveau succède
à la nuit, le début succède à la fin.
Un cycle de vie éternelle,
immuable depuis le premier jour de la création.
L'homme a appliqué cette loi naturelle
à sa propre vie et à sa propre mort.
À la vie succède la mort qui donne à son tour naissance
à une nouvelle vie.
Éternellement, l'âme immortelle migre
dans un nouveau corps, entame une nouvelle existence,
tend vers un nouveau but suprême.
- Mettant Psychose, Renaissance, Réincarnation.
Une idée aussi ancienne que l'humanité elle-même,
selon laquelle l'âme éternelle passe d'une vie à l'autre,
d'une enveloppe charnelle à l'autre,
et connaît ainsi tous les modes d'existence,
toutes les formes de vie du monde.
Une âme peut aussi d'un pôle à l'autre
et habiter tantôt un corps masculin,
tantôt un corps féminin, beau ou laid,
humain ou non-humain.
Lors de ce voyage, l'âme rencontre tous les possibles,
tous les extrêmes, tous les contraires de ce monde
et des autres mondes.
Elle développe ainsi sa conscience et son être conscient.
L'on pourrait comparer ce voyage de l'âme
à une spirale ascendante,
qui tend vers toujours plus de plénitude,
de maturité, d'expérience.
Dans l'hindouisme et le bouddhisme,
on retrouve cette image de la roue des existences,
ce cycle sans fin dans lequel l'âme immortelle
transite inlassablement d'un corps à l'autre.
Le sens de la réincarnation est de retrouver la liberté
originelle de l'âme qui aspire à l'éternité.
Toutes les cultures et les religions asiatiques
professent la doctrine de la réincarnation.
Et en tout premier lieu l'hindouisme et le bouddhisme,
les plus grandes religions orientales,
toutes deux originaires de l'Inde.
Ainsi les Védas, les premiers textes religieux indiens,
mentionnent le phénomène de la mort
et de la réincarnation.
Suivant les traces des grandes civilisations,
ces idées sont parvenues jusqu'en Occident,
longtemps avant notre ère.
Déjà, les grands philosophes de l'Antiquité
tels que Pythagore, Socrate ou Platon
professaient l'évolution progressive de la conscience
au-delà de la vie.
On retrouve cette croyance chez nos ancêtres les Celtes,
de même que chez presque tous les peuples européens.
Comme les Vikings, les Irlandais,
les Gallois ou les Germains.
- Mais qu'en est-il de l'église chrétienne,
qui rejette officiellement depuis 1500 ans
la doctrine de la réincarnation ?
On dit parfois que l'idée de la réincarnation
est antichrétienne
et incompatible avec l'enseignement du Christ.
En y regardant de plus près, l'on constate que cela est faux,
tant sur le plan théologique qu'historique.
Le juif Jésus est né dans un environnement
ou l'idée de la réincarnation était très familière.
Au sein des communautés juives de Palestine de l'époque
existaient divers groupes et confréries
qui croyaient en la réincarnation.
Comme par exemple les Esséniens et les Nazaréens,
des rangs desquels est issu non seulement Jean-Baptiste,
mais probablement aussi Jésus-Christ lui-même.
Dans les premiers siècles après Jésus-Christ,
l'idée de la réincarnation était encore admise.
Saint Jérôme, Saint Augustin et d'autres savants
des débuts du christianisme ne voyaient aucune
contradiction entre la réincarnation
et l'enseignement de Jésus-christ.
Ce n'est que plus tard,
aux alentours du 6ᵉ siècle après Jésus-Christ,
que la réincarnation fut officiellement
rejetée par l'Église.
En l'an 553,
lors du 5e concile œcuménique de Constantinople,
elle fut frappée d'anathème.
Et depuis, l'Église catholique a tenté
par tous les moyens d'empêcher la propagation
de la doctrine de la réincarnation.
Cependant, l'idée de la réincarnation s'est perpétuée
dans l'histoire spirituelle occidentale
et a trouvé un écho favorable chez de nombreux poètes,
penseurs et philosophes.
Paracelse, Leibnitz, Voltaire, Lessing,
Guth, Holderlin et beaucoup d'autres ont clairement
évoqué et défendu dans leurs œuvres
cette vision de la vie.
Ainsi le poète Christian Morgenstern se pose-t-il
la question suivante :
Combien de fois ai-je tourné la grande roue des existences ?
Combien de fois ai-je changé de corps,
d'habits et d'apparence ?
Wilhelm Busch, quant à lui, philosophe avec ironie.
Qu'en est-il de notre âme après notre trépas ?
Quitte-t-elle notre corps, lorsque sonne le glas ?
Je rêve bien souvent que jamais elles ne meurent.
Qu'éternelle rivière, grand aux oiseaux migrateurs
de son destin cruel, elles suivent le cours dans les airs,
condamnés à souffrir et à aimer toujours.
Que peut bien faire Wilhelm Busch aujourd'hui ?
La physique classique fondée par Isaac Newton
nous a permis de comprendre
et de maîtriser le monde d'aujourd'hui.
L'homme a exploré l'univers de la matière,
découvert les lois qui le régissent
et utiliser ce savoir
pour faire avancer le progrès technique.
La connaissance de ces lois naturelles
a profondément influencé sa vision du monde.
Une gigantesque machine, un système complexe
de matière en mouvement.
Et l'homme, propulsé dans ce mouvement d'horlogerie
universelle obéit aux mêmes lois.
Théoriquement, son organisme est semblable à une horloge,
au tic tac parfaitement régulier.
Seule une panne mécanique,
qu'on appelle alors maladie ou mort,
peut venir entraver son fonctionnement.
Tout est calculable, prévisible, réalisable.
Nous sommes dans un monde qui obéit aux règles
du bon sens et où rien n'est impossible.
Les progrès techniques de ces dernières années
ne confirment-ils pas l'aspect visionnaire
de la pensée humaine ?
N'avons-nous pas tout mise en œuvre
pour rendre la vie plus confortable et plus facile.
Pour parvenir à plus de bien-être, de plaisir,
de liberté et de bonheur.
Mais dans cette course effrénée aux idéaux,
le pendule de la polarité oscille lentement
mais irrésistiblement vers l'autre côté du miroir.
Il nous entraîne dans le monde mystérieux
et secret de l'esprit et de l'âme.
Peut-être dans ce monde spirituel,
pouvons-nous espérer atteindre les buts
que nous poursuivons en vain dans le monde matériel.
Nombreux sont ceux qui embarquent pour des voyages
intérieurs pleins de promesses,
à la recherche d'eux-mêmes.
Mais pour arriver au terme de ce voyage,
nous devons apprendre le langage de l'âme.
Sous la forme d'images mentales et de symboles,
ils délivrent des messages empreints d'une vérité profonde.
Son royaume est situé dans un pays lointain,
au-delà de la pensée rationnelle.
Dans le monde merveilleux des rêves,
de l'imaginaire et des sentiments.
C'est dans ce monde de l'âme,
libéré des contraintes de l'espace et du temps,
que jaillit la source des contes et des mythes,
des rites et des religions.
Nos ancêtres connaissaient ce monde
et se sentaient partie intégrante de cette entité cosmique
que l'on a baptisé de diverses manières.
La cause première.
La conscience universelle.
Le grand manitou.
Ou encore Brahma.
Yahvé.
Allah
ou Dieu.
Pourtant, chaque homme, dès qu'il vient au monde,
est séparé de cette entité divine.
Sa naissance charnelle le coupe de ses origines.
La mythologie chrétienne décrit cette chute
au sens religieux du terme,
comme un bannissement du paradis.
C'est le prix à payer pour goûter aux fruits de l'arbre
de la connaissance.
Le prix de la conscience individuelle,
de la faculté de l'homme à se connaître lui-même.
Le message essentiel de toutes les religions
est le retour aux origines.
Et chaque communauté religieuse cherche à sa manière
à retrouver le chemin du paradis originel.
Sur le chemin de la vie,
de nombreuses portes s'ouvrent derrière lesquelles
se cache la finalité suprême.
Quelle que soit la voie que nous choisissions,
quelles que soient les embûches
dont est semée notre parcours, ils mènent au même but.
Pour les chrétiens, le Royaume des cieux.
Pour les bouddhistes, le nirvana.
Et une fois parvenus au bout du chemin,
nous savons que toutes les portes ouvrent
sur la même demeure.
Cette demeure que nous quittons pour nous lancer
dans la grande aventure de la vie.
Le mandala est le symbole intemporel de ce modèle de la
création qu'évoquent toutes les religions.
Nous quittons le centre symbolique de l'unité
pour entrer dans le temps et l'espace.
Dans le monde matériel de la diversité.
Et quand notre cycle de vie est achevé,
nous revenons vers le centre,
vers l'origine de toute vie.
Ainsi, le mandala représente notre cycle de vie
et en même temps les structures fondamentales de la matière.
Des spirales, des cercles,
des enceintes concentriques
se forment au centre invisible du mandala.
Les mandalas sont partout.
Ils vont jusqu'aux confins de l'univers.
Nous les rencontrons dans le monde visible
qui nous entoure.
Mais ils existent également
dans les structures invisibles du microcosme.
Mandala et pendule.
Chaque symbole représente une loi de la création
et de la vie.
Au centre du mandala, symbole de l'unité,
règne la loi du silence dont découle toute force.
L'oscillation du pendule nous indique
le mouvement polaire et le rythme éternel de la vie.
Si nous modifions ce rythme,
nous bouleverserons l'équilibre des forces.
C'est toujours le trop ou le trop peu,
le manque ou l'abondance,
qui cause les problèmes de notre monde.
Si nous pouvions remplacer ce principe de l'opposition
par celui de la complémentarité,
alors de nombreux problèmes disparaîtraient d'eux-mêmes.
Actif ou passif,
fort ou faible,
donneur ou receveur.
Seul celui qui réunit en lui-même les deux opposés
du yin et du yang, le féminin et le masculin,
trouve son juste milieu.
Maintenir l'équilibre de notre balance intérieur,
c'est vivre en harmonie avec nous même.
Ce qui nous empêche de parvenir à cet état,
c'est l'abandon de l'une de ses moitiés.
Ce sont les schémas de comportement
que nous avons nous-mêmes établis
et ancrés dans la mémoire temporelle de notre inconscient.
S'il est vrai que nous sommes des âmes
et que nous nous réincarnons
sous les formes les plus diverses.
Alors, il est certain que tous les hommes viennent
au monde avec des atouts différents en main.
Ce qui signifie qu'à la naissance,
nous ne sommes pas vierges,
mais nous ne faisons que poursuivre
ce que nous avons jadis commencé.
La roue tourne depuis longtemps déjà.
Nous seuls, par nos pensées et nos actes,
avons donné l'élan décisif
et déterminé ainsi un rythme et une direction.
Même si dans le théâtre de nos incarnations,
les décors changent,
ils ne constituent que le cadre formel de la pièce
que nous avons nous-mêmes mis en scène.
Actions et réactions.
Forces et résistance.
Puissance et impuissance.
Victimes et bourreaux.
Causes et conséquences.
Cette loi universelle de la vie est
ce que les Indiens appellent le karma.
- Reprenons l'idée du karma,
sans toutefois dépasser ni trahir la pensée orientale.
Tout comme les boules de billard qui s'entrechoquent
et dont le mouvement quasi mécanique
est déterminé par la puissance de l'impact initial.
Toutes nos actions présentes et futures dépendent
de ce même impact.
Sur ce sujet, l'Orient est beaucoup plus ouvert,
beaucoup plus souple, pourrait-on dire.
La philosophie orientale est d'une grande richesse.
En fin de compte, nous devons nous plier
aux lois naturelles et ne pouvons pas véritablement
changer notre destinée.
Cette idée est bien connue en Occident.
Ainsi, le dicton populaire :
tel est pris qui croyait prendre.
Ou l'enseignement biblique :
on ne récolte que ce que l'on a semé.
Expriment et rejoignent le principe du karma.
Pourtant, il faut se garder d'appliquer la loi du talion
telle qu'elle est énoncée dans L'ancien Testament.
Œil pour œil, dent pour dent.
Tout simplement parce qu'elle ne prend pas en compte
le fait qu'un acte présent
est toujours la conséquence d'actes passés.
Au contraire, chacun doit tirer les leçons
de son expérience passée.
Afin d'y trouver les solutions adaptées
à sa situation présente.
Même si la récolte est maigre,
nous pouvons en tirer profit sans jamais oublier
que c'est la récolte d'aujourd'hui,
qui fait le semis de demain.
Ainsi, c'est le présent qui détermine notre avenir.
Mais bien sûr, le paysan ne peut récolter
que ce qu'il a semé.
Le paysan qui plante son riz ne s'attend pas à récolter
autre chose que du riz.
Et il a bien raison !
Cette contradiction apparente
entre le principe du karma,
appliqué à la justice
et le concept judéo-chrétien de la grâce, d'autre part,
n'est en réalité pas une contradiction.
Un principe conditionne l'autre.
Et ces deux courants, ces deux traditions,
débouchent elles-mêmes sur une troisième voie.
L'orient met davantage l'accent sur le karma,
le catholicisme sur la grâce.
Et c'est précisément la loi du karma,
qui nous permet de mûrir,
de faire des expériences dans cette vie,
mais également d'une vie à l'autre,
et nous amène à comprendre
que nous ne pouvons plus avancer seul.
Nous demandons alors de l'aide
et ce n'est qu'ainsi que nous pouvons connaître la grâce.
Dans la tradition chrétienne,
on demande à celui qui veut guérir, crois-tu en moi ?
Et l'homme répond alors à Jésus. Oui !
Cela signifie qu'il possède la maturité suffisante
pour poser cette question et obtenir cette réponse,
mais aussi qu'il a pris conscience de son impuissance
à résoudre seul ses problèmes,
cela suppose une certaine humilité.
Et c'est précisément le karma qui nous permet d'atteindre
ce degré d'humilité et de connaître
ainsi la grâce de la guérison.
Le karma, loi de l'équilibre, nous permet d'accéder
à des choses que nous ignorons.
Comme nous n'avons encore aucune expérience.
Souvent, les personnes qui participent à des séances
de réincarnation se positionnent tout d'abord en victimes.
Puis, au fil de la thérapie,
elles sortent de ce rôle de victime
pour devenir acteurs de leur propre existence.
Et si l'on continue, le phénomène s'inverse de nouveau
et les patients retrouvent leur rôle initial de victime.
Ce processus est sans fin.
Dans tous les cas, un équilibre se crée au fil des séances.
Le karma est la loi qui assure l'harmonie
qui permet d'équilibrer les deux plateaux de la balance.
Nous pouvons ainsi nous retrouver nous-
mêmes dans tous ces rôles différents,
alternativement acteurs ou victimes.
Et il est beaucoup plus utile de chercher des réponses
en nous-mêmes que de rejeter nos propres fautes sur autrui.
Si nous nous y appliquons, beaucoup de choses
changeront automatiquement dans notre vie.
Tant sur le plan individuel,
que dans nos rapports avec les autres.
Un jour, nous cesserons de polluer l'eau
de génération en génération,
car nous aurons compris que c'est nous-mêmes
qui en subissons les conséquences.
Nous aurons pris conscience que nous seuls
récoltons le fruit de nos efforts et de nos erreurs.
Peu à peu, notre personnalité se construit.
En effet par nos pensées et nos actes,
nous concevons nous-mêmes le logiciel
qui régit notre vie, selon le principe suivant :
"input égale output".
Ce que l'on donne égal, ce que l'on reçoit.
Quelque part en nous, dans les profondeurs mystérieuses
de ce que nous appelons conscience,
âme ou encore psychisme.
Se trouve la clé qui permet de modifier ce logiciel.
Ce n'est que la nuit, lorsque nous rêvons,
que nous explorons le tréfonds de notre conscience.
En nous réveillant, nous retournons aux commandes centrales.
Nous retrouvons la perception consciente.
Notre logiciel est alors réactivé
et il nous transmet des informations
par l'intermédiaire de nos organes sensoriels.
Nous évaluons, trions, contrôlons, choisissons et décidons,
pour pouvoir agir et réagir en conséquence
dans la vie quotidienne.
Est-elle une pluie de météorites ?
Les pensées fusent en permanence à travers l'espace.
Lancent des éclairs, tournent un moment
comme en orbite autour d'un même thème, puis s'éteignent.
Cette centrale d'émission et de réception
est régie par le ratio ou raison, une puissante machine
aux étonnantes capacités de commandement.
Ces compétences la pensée rationnelle et analytique,
le bon sens en action.
Son domicile fixe l'hémisphère gauche du cerveau.
Le ratio maîtrise la situation, du moins en apparence.
Car dans l'ombre, au-delà de la perception consciente,
agit une force qui influence son action quotidienne
de manière discrète, mais décisive.
Tout près de la commande centrale se trouve
une énorme banque de données
qui contient la somme de nos expériences.
Tout ce que nous avons vu ou vécu, ce qui nous a touchés,
rendu heureux ou mené au désespoir.
Une mémoire absolue sans faille qui contient
la somme des expériences de nos nombreuses vies.
Une mémoire aux capacités et à la durée de vie illimitée.
Cette banque de données subjective de l'inconscient
contrôle notre vie, laisse agir la raison
ou la fait hésiter et décide selon un principe binaire
de ce qui est bon ou mauvais pour nous.
Continuons à nous enfoncer dans les profondeurs
de l'inconscient humain.
La lumière de la conscience est à présent trop lointaine
pour que nous puissions l'atteindre.
Obscurité, enfer, royaume des ombres,
autant de lieux peuplés de nos propres démons
que nous avons proscrits,
jeter aux oubliettes.
De peur qu'il ne déforme la belle image
que nous avons de nous-mêmes,
ne dévoile les pans obscurs de notre personnalité,
ne révèle nos pulsions, notre agressivité,
notre lâcheté, notre violence et notre mauvaise foi.
Nous ne sommes ni ange ni démon,
mais simplement des humains jetés
dans un monde à deux pôles.
Et entre ces deux pôles,
notre personnalité comporte bien des zones d'ombre.
Nous ne devons pas les refouler,
mais les regarder en face.
Nos démons attendent depuis bien longtemps leur rédemption.
- À peine avons-nous prononcé le mot ombre
que l'image du cachot s'impose à nous.
Le royaume des ombres que la mythologie appelle l'enfer,
le lieu où tout est réuni
et que nous cherchons à ignorer.
Auxquels nous refusons de nous identifier.
On peut mesurer la force de cette image,
à notre façon de réagir aux compliments ou aux reproches.
Si l'on me félicite, je me frappe la poitrine
en disant oui, je suis comme ça.
Mais que l'on me critique, que l'on me blâme
et je m'exclame aussitôt : je n'y suis pour rien.
Nous rejetons les reproches,
nous les expédions au royaume des ombres.
Mais on ne peut aller jusqu'au bout du chemin
de l'individualisation, de la guérison
et atteindre à la plénitude,
que si l'on réconcilie en soi-même l'ombre et la lumière.
C'est ainsi que naît le moi, au sens jungien du terme.
Si je reconnais la part d'étrangeté qui est en moi,
si je peux accepter que mon âme me soit étrangère.
Alors, je ne rejetterai plus mes fautes sur les autres.
Je n'aurais plus peur de l'inconnu,
je ne ressentirai plus de haine.
Je reconnaîtrai en l'autre ce que j'ai reconnu en moi-même
et je deviendrai ainsi plus tolérant.
Ainsi, notre environnement agit comme un miroir
et nous renvoie l'image de ce qui est essentiel,
de ce qui nous manque pour être totalement guéri.
Parfois, cette part d'ombre
que nous renvoie notre miroir, nous déplaît.
En effet, nous possédons des antennes
qui nous permettent d'opérer une sélection,
de ne percevoir que ce qui nous arrange.
Nous fonctionnons comme une radio.
Ce que nous captons dépend de la bande de fréquence
que nous avons choisi.
Dans le langage courant, on parle souvent de filtres,
de prismes, pour exprimer cette idée.
C'est exactement cela.
Nous voyons à travers un prisme,
qui déforme notre image de la réalité.
Or, tout ce que nous vivons a un sens,
signifie quelque chose,
mais il ne s'agit pas d'une punition.
La conception selon laquelle le karma
serait une punition divine est une invention humaine.
Au bout du compte, notre but est d'atteindre l'équilibre,
d'apprendre, d'avancer sur le chemin de la connaissance.
Et une fois que nous sommes parvenus à nous réconcilier
avec notre part d'ombre,
que nous sommes capables de nous reconnaître dans tout.
De cesser de juger, de vivre dans la projection de soi.
Alors, nous sommes libres.
On peut également dire que cette faculté
de nous réconcilier avec notre part d'ombre,
nous permet d'accéder au paradis ou à l'enfer.
Mais si nous ne nous réconcilions pas
avec notre part d'ombre, notre vie risque fort,
en effet, de devenir un enfer.
Si, au contraire, nous perçons ces ténèbres,
si nous les éclairons, nous trouverons notre voie
et gagneront le paradis.
Le paradis ou l'enfer.
Nous avons toujours le choix
et nous avons souvent choisi.
C'est au niveau de l'inconscient,
que s'opèrent ces choix, parfois dramatiques.
Des centaines de productions personnelles sont
stockées dans la cinémathèque de notre vie.
Ce sont des films que nous avons tournés nous-mêmes
et dans lesquels nous jouons le rôle principal.
Des drames, des comédies, des histoires d'amour,
de sexe et de violence.
Parfois, ce sont des œuvres monumentales
et parfois de brefs épisodes à la fin prématurée.
Quel que soit le film que nous projetons,
il nous renvoie toujours vers notre propre passé.
Faut-il sortir ses vieux films de leur boîte ?
Ne devons-nous pas craindre d'être écrasés
sous le poids de notre fardeau ?
Par chance, la nature nous a dotés de la faculté d'oublier,
disent les uns.
Courage, libérons-nous de nos vieux démons,
pensent les autres.
C'est notre imaginaire qui, tel un projecteur,
nous renvoie ses anciennes images, leur redonne vie.
Notre imaginaire qui parle la langue vraie
et intemporelle de l'âme.
La rétrospective a pour titre :
Thérapie de la réincarnation.
- Pendant que vous plongez dans un océan de calme
et de détente
et que vous vous enfoncez dans les profondeurs de votre âme.
Dans cette partie secrète de vous-même.
Dans un monde de plénitude et de silence.
Laissez-vous entraîner dans le royaume des sons
et des vibrations.
Profondément, toujours plus profondément.
Jusqu'aux portes de la sagesse.
Et pendant que vous vous laissez glisser,
Remontez le temps toujours plus loin
jusqu'au moment de votre naissance.
Puis continuez jusqu'au stade de votre conception,
puis plus loin encore
et remontez le temps jusqu'à ce que vous vous rappeliez
un événement qui a marqué votre vie.
Maintenant où êtes-vous ?
Que se passe-t-il ?
- Je suis sur un champ de bataille.
C'est la guerre.
J'entends les tambours et les coups de feu.
Des coups de canon.
Il y a un soldat.
Il porte un drapeau.
Il m'appelle !
Mais je ne peux pas le rejoindre.
Je ne peux pas bouger.
Je suis allongé à terre, blessé.
Les autres continuent à marcher.
S'il me laisse ici, je vais mourir.
J'ai peur.
J'ai peur de mourir !
- Bien, maintenant, essayez de ressentir
plus précisément la peur qui vous habite
et regardez ce qu'il se passe.
Que se passe-t-il ?
- Je sais que je vais mourir.
Je veux regarder s'il y a quelqu'un,
mais je ne vois plus rien.
Juste un voile blanc.
Tout tremble.
Puis c'est fini.
- Que percevez-vous encore ?
- J'entends une explosion au loin.
Ils ont certainement touché
la réserve de munitions du camp.
- Oui, et que pensez-vous en ce moment ?
- Que la victoire m'importe peu,
puisque j'ai perdu tout le reste.
- Bien, maintenant, revenez une nouvelle fois
en arrière au moment où vous avez été touché.
- Devant !
Je suis en première ligne.
Nous nous engageons dans une grande bataille.
- Oui ! Et que se passe-t-il encore ?
- J'entends des coups de canon,
quelque chose explose devant moi !
On me bouscule.
J'ai la sensation d'être écartelé.
- Oui et que ressentez-vous en ce moment précis ?
Que ressentez-vous exactement ?
- Maintenant, c'est terminé.
Alors que la bataille n'a même pas commencé.
- Sur ces images filmées lors d'une séance de thérapie.
On voit bien avec quelle intensité émotionnelle
le patient vit ses images mentales.
Il ressent presque physiquement les douleurs
qu'ont provoquées sa blessure.
Puis, il revit sa mort solitaire.
On nous demande souvent quelle est la nature
des images qui se forment dans l'esprit du patient
lors des séances.
Ne peut-il pas s'agir de simples souvenirs,
d'images de films qu'il a vues dans sa vie,
de souvenirs de romans qu'il a lu ?
Pour être précis, c'est en effet de cela qu'il s'agit.
Des bribes de souvenirs, de romans,
de films resurgissent durant les séances.
En fait, il s'agit d'un mélange d'images
issues de l'inconscient, d'images symboliques
et de souvenirs de la vie actuelle,
mais également de réminiscences de vies antérieures.
Mais la nature de ces souvenirs est sans importance.
Ce sont toujours des images propres au patient
qui font apparaître la trame de sa vie,
révèlent son caractère
et reviennent dans un ordre bien précis.
Chez toutes les autres personnes,
ces images seraient très différentes.
Dans la thérapie, il s'agit ensuite de saisir,
de connaître et de prendre conscience
des caractéristiques particulières
et de la structure de la personnalité de chaque individu.
Lors de la séance de thérapie,
notre client nous raconte sa vie.
Mais là, il est meunier et vit avec sa famille.
Un jour, il quitte cette famille,
s'engage comme soldat dans les troupes du roi
et part au combat pour défendre ses nobles idéaux.
- Il y a une grande bataille à proximité de notre village.
C'est de la folie pure !
Des milliers de gens, des cavaliers, des canons.
Tout le monde s'enfuit !
- Et comment vous sentez vous ?
- Terriblement excité !
Enfin, il se passe quelque.
Enfin, nous pouvons nous battre
et montrer à nos ennemis que nous sommes les plus forts.
- Et que se passe-t-il encore ?
- Nous avons subi une cuisante défaite.
C'est la débâcle.
C'est affreux, il y a des morts partout.
- Oui et que faites-vous en ce moment ?
- Je cours.
Pour sauver ma vie et mon drapeau.
Il faut que je mette le drapeau en sûreté.
- Et où courriez-vous ?
- Au village !
Qu'est devenu ma famille ?
Peut-être que je peux encore faire quelque chose.
J'ai très peur, qu'il leur soit arrivé malheur.
Le moulin est en flammes.
Il n'y a personne !
Rien que des soldats.
Partout, des soldats.
Il faut que je sauve ma famille.
- Et que faites-vous ensuite ?
- Je les cherche !
Non, c'est pas possible.
Ma femme !
Elle est étendue là, morte.
Je retourne au village en courant.
Et soudain je vois notre charrette.
Elle se dirige droit vers moi.
- Oui, reconnaissez-vous quelqu'un ?
- Oui, oui.
Mes parents sont assis sur le siège du cocher.
Mon fils est avec eux.
Quelque chose d'incandescence tombe sur la voiture.
- Oui et où exactement ?
- Sur mon fils. Il tombe !
Tout commence à brûler.
- Vous venez d'assister à une scène dramatique
revécu lors d'une séance de thérapie.
Et beaucoup d'entre vous se demandent :
qu'est-ce que cela apporte de revivre tout cela ?
À la vérité, la thérapie de la réincarnation
a pour but, en faisant revivre aux patients
des vies antérieures, des expériences passées,
de lui permettre d'accéder dans sa vie actuelle
à un degré de conscience supérieur.
Elle peut également nous apprendre à reconnaître
et à déjouer les pièges dans lesquels
nous ne cessons de retomber tout au long de notre vie.
La thérapie de la réincarnation est une excellente
technique d'exploration de l'inconscient,
car d'une part, elle implique le patient,
c'est lui qui revit ses scènes
et d'autre part, le fait de voyager dans le temps
et de revivre sa propre vie antérieure
crée la distance nécessaire à l'identification
de sa propre structure psychique élémentaire.
En thérapie de la réincarnation,
l'on s'efforce toujours de créer un lien
entre la vie antérieure et la vie actuelle.
Cet élément est essentiel lors des séances
et l'on tente de l'analyser
et d'établir le rapport entre tous les thèmes évoqués.
Tout le vécu que nous avons fait resurgir
et notre vie actuelle.
Si l'on prend l'exemple de notre client.
On pourrait se demander dans quelle mesure,
dans la situation où il s'est trouvé jadis.
Il a vraiment fui ses responsabilités,
notamment ses responsabilités familiales.
Il est parti à l'aventure
et a choisi de prendre des responsabilités plus importantes,
qui peut être dans la situation d'alors, le dépassait.
Dans ce sens, la thérapie de la réincarnation est,
d'après moi, l'une des meilleures techniques
permettant d'accéder à la connaissance de soi.
Au fronton du temple de Delphes figurait l'inscription :
Connais-toi toi-même,
car de tout temps, l'homme a su que le changement
et le progrès ne pouvaient se produire
que grâce à la connaissance
et à l'évolution de la conscience.
Cette invitation à la connaissance de soi
comptait parmi les préceptes essentiels
d'une doctrine ancestrale de la sagesse,
connue non seulement dans la Grèce antique,
mais également dans toutes les grandes civilisations
antérieures à l'ère chrétienne et
qui constitue le fondement de nos religions actuelles.
- Presque toutes les grandes civilisations,
mais également les civilisations que nous qualifions
à tort de primitives, c'est-à-dire les sociétés archaïques.
Concevaient le monde comme un cosmos,
un tout organisé, régi par des lois
et doté d'un sens propre.
Pars pro toto dit la philosophie ésotérique.
La partie pour le tout.
La génétique moderne confirme cette hypothèse.
Chaque cellule du corps humain contient
des informations sur l'être humain tout entier
et peut-être même plus encore.
Nous en revenons donc au principe
que des lois précises régissent notre univers
et que le tout est un cosmos
dont tous les éléments sont liés.
C'est sur ce précepte fondateur
de la pensée ésotérique
qu'est également fondée la célèbre loi
de l'analogie de Hermès Trismégiste.
Cette figure que l'on retrouve
dans la mythologie égyptienne.
Selon la loi de l'analogie.
Ce qui est en haut est semblable à ce qui est en bas.
Ce principe existe dans toutes les religions,
y compris dans la religion chrétienne.
Dans le Notre Père par exemple,
que ta volonté soit faite sur la terre comme au ciel,
en haut comme en bas.
Dans un passage clé de son œuvre médicale,
Paracelse cite l'analogie suivante :
Microcosme égal, macrocosme.
Cette analogie entre les hommes et la terre
a pour but de mettre en évidence leurs destins parallèles,
mais également d'imposer cette vision de l'homme
en tant que tout, en tant qu'être possédant un corps,
une âme et un esprit.
Et bon nombre de problèmes que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui, et en particulier dans le domaine
de la médecine, proviennent de ce découpage
de l'homme en différents morceaux,
le corps, l'âme et l'esprit.
Tout cela provoque un éclatement
qui conduit à de graves erreurs.
Il ne s'agit pas de juger ses erreurs,
mais de constater la destruction d'un tout.
La médecine ésotérique tente un retour
aux écrits de Paracelse.
Elle cherche à rattacher à l'ensemble
le chaînon manquant pour parvenir à la guérison.
Tout ce qui est refoulé par notre conscience
a tendance à resurgir dans notre corps
et une médecine qui a pour but de guérir
doit prendre tous ces phénomènes en considération
et chercher à déterminer les symptômes.
Afin de recréer l'harmonie de l'âme et du corps.
Dans le diagnostic de notre médecin,
dans les symptômes qu'il nous révèle.
Nous devons trouver le principe manquant,
l'intégrer de nouveau dans notre conscience
pour trouver la voie de la guérison.
Au bout du compte,
cette médecine n'a bien entendu pas pour but
de faire disparaître les symptômes,
mais bien au contraire de les faire émerger.
Car on ne fait pas disparaître les symptômes,
on ne fait que les écarter.
Et ils réapparaissent sous une forme généralement aggravée.
Mais d'une certaine manière,
ces manifestations sont positives.
Car elles nous permettent d'avancer
et de faire un pas en avant.
En ce sens, la connaissance de soi
est la seule thérapeutique
qui conduise véritablement à la guérison.
Cependant, le cheminement intérieur ressemble
fort à une expédition à l'issue incertaine.
Une expédition au cours de laquelle on plonge
dans un torrent de larmes retenue.
Pour atteindre les tréfonds de la culpabilité,
de la douleur et découvrir enfin les multiples
facettes de notre personnalité.
Mais là où est l'ombre est aussi la lumière.
Au bout du tunnel, la clarté nous aveugle.
La lumière jaillit au cœur de notre conscience.
Nous brûlons d'un feu immortel.
Nous sommes pleins d'une énergie vitale inépuisable.
Rares sont ceux qui perçoivent consciemment
ce centre vital.
L'illumination est réservée aux seuls élus.
Du moins, semble-t-il.
Et pourtant, nous sentons dans ces instants de lumière,
un peu de cette force qui est une partie de nous-mêmes.
C'est ici que meurt l'illusion de la polarité.
Cette partie de nous-même sait
que le monde des contraires n'existe pas.
Si une goutte d'eau avait une conscience,
elle se prendrait pour un être autonome, un individu.
Ce n'est qu'en se fondant à nouveau dans l'océan
d'où elle vient, en retrouvant son élément naturel,
qu'elle saurait que tout n'est qu'illusion.
Nous aussi, nous quittons sans cesse la mère
du pur esprit et de l'énergie vitale éternelle.
Nous nous séparons de la conscience universelle
pour habiter un corps humain.
Mais nous en portons avec nous notre âme.
Une goutte de cette conscience vivante,
indivisible, immortelle et éternelle.
Ayons confiance en la force de l'étincelle divine
que nous avons rapportée de l'océan de la vie.
Elle contient toute l'énergie et toute la sagesse
qui nous permettent de maîtriser notre existence,
de vivre en homme responsable.
Et elle contient toute la joie
et tout le bonheur du monde
que nous ne pouvons trouver qu'en nous-mêmes.